Well,
the American theater is lousy with
hidden gems,
but I think in particular there are a
lot of place.
What used to be,
well,
they're still called wellmade place,
the thirties and forties that fell out
of fashion when the fashion and American
theater turned towards more personal
expressionistic playwriting at Tennessee
Williams really marks the big change in
direction here.
Uh,
there's still a lot to be said for the
wellmade witty,
clever three act comedy.
Uh,
uh,
there's a playwright named sn Bearman,
Sam Bearman,
who wrote these kinds of,
of social comedies that are actually
extremely sharp and,
and,
and still quite provocative.
Uh,
he has a play called biography,
which is about to be produced off
Broadway that I'm going to see that I've
actually seen that produced an excited
by it.
Uh,
John Ruetten,
another purveyor of wellmade boulevard
theater that's actually much more
challenging and interesting than you
might expect.
There's a wonderful play called the
voice of the turtle three character play
that has never had a modern production
on the east coast so far as I know,
uh,
the British playwrights,
terence Radigan in particular who,
who are also totally unfashionable
because of their,
their being rooted in traditional ways
of play construction.
I'm not saying that this is the best or
the only way to write a play.
I like Tennessee Williams as much as the
next guy and Sam Shepard and,
and all sorts of different ways of
writing plays,
but I don't think that that what worked
in the thirties and forties should be
disregarded simply because it is no
longer fashionable.
And that's something that I sort of
crusade for in my own writing.
I look for productions of playwrights
like that.
David cromer from Chicago I think is the
most gifted young director in America.
He had a real setback.
He just made his Broadway debut last
month with the what was supposed to be a
repertory production to Neil Simon plays
and they closed it after the first one
opened and before the second one got
open.
That's not going to stop him.
This is a guy who is his imagination
just oozes out of his pores.
He did an off Broadway production of our
town,
uh,
last season.
It's still running in which he played
the stage manager.
Nowadays,
everybody seen our town.
Your high school did it.
You probably did it when you were in,
in high school.
It is an utterly familiar play and
cromer without distorting it,
without transforming it,
beyond recognition made an absolutely
new and fresh and every moment of it was
alive.
He did the same thing with the
production of the glass menagerie that I
saw in Kansas City last year.
The same thing with the production of
William enjoys a picnic that I saw in
Chicago two years ago.
Uh,
I got onto him because I travel in.
Most other critics don't.
And so I was aware of him earlier than,
than he was generally known in New York.
And now he,
he is at the top of the list of
directors whose work I will travel to
see.
He excites me.